this is an indirect kiss ooh and
indirect is ooh Oh juice box cusp it is
mad wash yeah cuz it is magic now magic
saliva uh so this is an episode is this
the first time we see Stephens mother
like we see her it swelling Statue form
yeah but but we do this here
um I've been looking at the episode my
spine oh hey guys even people are like
the Amazon there's it backwards and
stuff it's like you're not really even
fucking Amazon kinking why can't anybody
just fucking release them in the proper
order so I'm checking um it it looks
like the next few are in the right order
um but yeah so if I'm right I think this
is the first time we see the mother in
the statue um and Stephen accidentally
or he doesn't accidentally cracks her
gem and has to get it fixed and turns
out Stephens tears or at least Rose's
tears could heal but his tears can't uh
hi time any of the cheers to Kim yeah on
top of it just has a hard time crying
and then at the very end when he does
which day which I do love a line what do
you have a hard time crying you cried
about snakes earlier today oh that was
really funny uh but even he does cry it
still doesn't work so he finds out uh by
healing
Connie's site I she no longer needs
glasses that his spit hello perry has
healing powers so that's what a random
superpower I know that's gonna be really
weird in future episodes with someone's
damage HS like there you go it's a whole
bunch of loogies um so yeah it's a
couple interesting angles to take this
at I mean I get I really like when
because I think it plays a little
against type that he does not cry for
his mother because he doesn't know her
and it's not it's like he wants to he
wants to be able to cry once it feel
like well his girlfriend
before yeah no go on yeah but but but
even that's like really and that is
really sad because everyone should you
know know my parents and stuff like that
um but you know he does not have a
connection here's all these great things
that he knows then she probably is great
but it's different than actually feeling
the person experiencing um and stuff so
I really like that I thought that was
actually you know because most witches
had just think of mother ok the tear
comes or whatever and how wonderful she
probably was but I like that he doesn't
have that connection um you know Kay
he's just never met her uh so I like
that I like how um I guess the episode
the moral the episode is kind of just
would you say that the moral is it's
okay to cry I mean is that kind of the
angle cuz I don't think anything built
up like it's bad to cry beforehand I
don't know if there's a moral per se
just did I I don't know if it was if
it's okay to cry because he wanted to
cry the whole yeah yeah there's nothing
I said let go what your words you're
crying or anything like that I mean it's
just a bunch of stuff yeah maybe it's
just just maybe that's it um it does
tackle sort of an interesting uh
interesting thing is that for some
people it is it is hard to cry and I
don't mean that all's I get insult it
gets those who do cry or insult against
those who have a hard time crying
whatever it's just for some people it is
very difficult um even when you know I
mean I know like there's times where
it's like Nonna you you lost your head
this morning and started bawling sad
it's very sad um but yeah but there are
times where it's like even when you know
it's healthy it's like no like I need to
do this I need to cry need to get this
Alex sometimes it's difficult it just
has to come at a certain time and it's
hard to force um so I do kind of like
they were addressing that um other
people cry the drop of a hat
did that my first review and actually I
actually job to add one a guy cry when
I'm forced to watch the Smurfs
yeah that's just where it goes um but
yeah it's uh is so it was good I like
that we know you know we find out more
okay here one other thing I thought was
interesting uh I'm sorry I'm sorry
taking this all over uh but that's okay
because you set the camera up like an
idiot I have to like lean into but no I
was trying to get the light we still
don't know well you're willing to film
in the often he's still only have any
light out well you wouldn't let us film
out there because she said it looks like
a disaster area well yeah to play the
cleanest okay what would a film maybe
the next will fill on your tuned index I
see where we're filming by instead it's
like like oh I see the whole thing from
over here alright here you gonna be dr.
claw I'll get you next time gadget oh
stop it stop it oh cool feline cancer
really gotta talk um but uh don't be the
other interesting thing uh are you
picking up on this too I mean cuz okay
they all obviously really like rose and
they remember her finally stuff pearl
really seems to like Rose well if you
look at it I think pearl probably had
way more in common with Rose than any of
the others then she doesn't seem like
the most responsive pearl is the most
primp Rose coming into the shine now
you're really gonna die no no I'm gonna
totally do it from over here okay it's
gonna be the ninja review no uh
pearl I thought was the most prim proper
but yeah oh where did he go such a dead
I don't do it like this
so pearl was the most premium proper I
thought about oh three there she started
the Flemish project
anyway if you wanna I was having a
thought no you weren't you were having
an ass moment um trying to stay in the
cage oh god somewhere your room come
find me
all right are you Peter all right fine
readjusted yes
okay well that's why I was really here
okay well point B mm-hm Rose is a healer
she seems fairly nice from what everyone
says every buses are very much pearl is
the prim proper one Bree pretty dainty
she's kind of wavy you know she's got
the pastel colors and also neurotic I'm
always super organized super panicky I
just I always get the impression that
Rose may have been I don't put this you
know how garnet and amethyst feel like
somehow they connect together even
though they're kind of opposites well I
guess I think um whew they complement
each other like I feel like rose and
pearl would have been the same way
whereas pearl is more neurotic Rose
would have been a little more laid-back
but their personalities are still some
real instead they complete each other
yeah they complete each other and they
click um I I don't get that from garnet
or amethyst when it comes to pearl I get
like girls always panicking that garnet
or amethyst are gonna fuck something up
well they both seem very much like you
know just the action-oriented
here we go yeah they seem very much like
the the action-oriented Pele you know
garnet amethyst they're you know to go
in rush yo with amethyst is very much
hey let's just have fun and our girl is
the type a person yeah um and uh yeah
but now the
the interesting thing is like even with
that uh you know cuz we can't Cora and
stuff like that that's opened up um you
know is is it like a friendly love is it
a sisterly love or is it like a couple
love you know or even whistle yeah I
mean or even like a warrior's love or
something like that right well she had a
kid well
was an attic kid so I would well uh no
no no but no but that could be even more
or I mean it could be like idiom Oh what
was I gonna like this I mean it could be
a sort of something where it's like she
looked at her like a teacher sort of
like a mentor you know a teacher and
student loan as well so because there's
clearly something she has it's not just
oh hey we worked well off each other's
like she's got something I'm considering
we haven't seen much of Rose I don't
know if we could really say I mean I
guess we can't really find out yeah but
I mean to me it feels more like than
just a um you know like yeah we got
along kind of thing I'm because like
she's really obsessed with that place
not being torn down and oh yeah just go
through go through the place where she
used to come all the time and just you
know
okay well keep this in mind you know
there could be a very simple explanation
for some of that too which is pearl
hates messes and so it sounds like a
beautiful place now it's taken over by
thorn bushes or whatever so yeah but
even before it could have been the
double whammy of like oh not only is it
not how I remember it it's also a
fucking mess it could be just kind like
a fangirl thing - I guess I kind of
falls on to the mentor thing though as
well because everything seems to be
really praising her or to you know
really respect her and stuff but she get
the impression that pearl and Rose just
really got along mm I hate to say it I
get the impression that if pearl was
gonna pick for somebody to die in the
group it would not have been bro that's
all I'm saying probably bad um but yeah
cuz she seems to talk to most about Rose
um I've known say just I never quite
picked up cuz I saw those all three but
then this one I'm like yeah like she
really seems to talk about her a lot um
so and it's interesting and most of the
stuff that's always like the most lovely
stuff is usually from pearl um but yet
could be could be a mentor thing could
be just best pals I mean good could be
like a sisterly thing or something I
don't know um but yeah I like this one
and I like the Iowas I was doing an
episode not like the plot points of well
now we know the gems can break and what
happens makes you talk backwards and
turns into mr. fantastic yes I saw that
like some
animation on her cattle nightmare fuel
ish um I was when Stephen was trying to
cry and squeezy yeah that was definitely
I kept thinking like pop out or
something um but uh yeah a lot of funny
expressions too when Connie is trying to
get the story out but me stupid I mean
those are some fun expressions uh but ya
know I thought was good we found out a
good deal it had some genuinely nice
emotion to it - I like that weird bit
where he thinks he sees the Statue
reaching out towards him and then it's
just the statue standing there and
that's a nice little oh that was there
real is that something in the water
they just imagine that so that I like
that um no it's a good episode and what
a helping toot the indirect kiss is
actually not a very big part of it or
something that pops up at the end and
it's like even though it's called it
indirect kiss although maybe maybe it's
the mother indirectly kissing her son
you know the crying thing some how about
I don't know they don't feel everything
yet but uh but no I I do think that's
because I'm saying myself well how is
this indirect kiss gonna happen cuz
that's what's called and I thought that
wasn't fine way to do it but that was
interesting she still kept the glasses
too like she just popped out she popped
last Hey identity maybe I don't know it
was getting too confusing for the
animators maybe they're just like you
know what we have this drawing but the
chart show staying a model is the best
thing to do so it's like where we have
the toys made because this is where it's
at just listen to the chart so um yeah a
good episode I think we're getting
pretty close to the end of the first
season actually so if again going kind
of by the Amazon thing but I think
there's only like two left I think now
it turns out that the next three they're
gonna run are all from season four which
hasn't even been there - I'll watch it
yeah see you there